[Applause]
[Music]
they're using pepper spray and water and
tear gas against the children is this
the human rights of europe ten days
we've been here without water
temperatures are minus five and what can
we do where are the human rights
organizations we were a good country
they invaded iraq in 2003 we've lost
everything we've sold our cars and sold
our houses they've destroyed our country
and now this is their human rights
[Music]
[Music]
the problem is if we don't save those
people we would both lose both belarus
and to an even bigger extent the
european union which didn't let through
the refugees to the eu territory
that's why i proposed on solving the
situation in general we agreed with
merkel but we won't talk about it
specifically
while alexander lukashenko tries to
extract from the eu the concessions he
wants the situation on the border
worsens
the numbers are growing the temperatures
are plunging the desperation increases
and with it the likelihood of more big
sashes assad vague al-jazeera poland